the idea of what we should be testing is
a very hotly debated because there's a
certain objectivity that we think we
have once we standardize things and we
give it the same tests to everyone and
there is some truth to that that the
more you standardize a test the more you
kind of give everyone the opportunity to
to perform on that test there so there
is some argument to be made towards
standardization but we don't have
standardized minds I mean no one has a
standardized mind there's no such thing
as as an average mind so every one of us
every unique individual has a dynamic
system of not just cognitive processes
but motivational processes dreams
desires I formulated a theory called it
the theory of personal intelligence
because I argued I wanted to shift our
focus of analysis from compare taking
one aspect that we are saying this is
the measure of intelligence whether it's
a standardized test or whether it's an
IQ test we say well this is we've
decided as a society that's our measure
of intelligence and then we compare
everyone to each other on that one
metric I wanted to remove it to a
personal level and recognize that well
within a person every single one of us
has a combination of traits and we can
compensate for lower levels of one trait
with higher levels of another trait for
instance we can compensate with lower
levels of IQ with grit you know or with
perseverance so there's we're capable of
mixing and matching our own unique
profile of characteristics and such
really fascinating exciting ways that
make us who we are that make that's what
makes us a whole person so when it comes
to testing I'm not necessarily against
testing and not actually against using
standardized tests as a way of measuring
learning outcomes but as a way of
measuring human potential not down with
that a really great report came out
recently called talent on the sidelines
which found very clearly that our ethnic
minority students our ethnic and racial
minority students are not being
identified in gifted talented programs
period and and you know we need to call
this out we need to make this here's
there's some wonderful researchers who
are trying to to to
to correct this like Joey Lawson Davis
for instance trying to figure out what
is going on there what we can do you
know when you have very poverty-stricken
environments for instance it's not as
easy to get the opportunities to display
your brilliance it's not as easy to to
learn when people all around you are
dying when people are around you when
you are not being fed you know it's very
hard to show your intellectual
intellectual brilliance it is a fact
that there's a huge under-representation
of ethnic and racial minority students
in gifted and talented education and I
do not believe that ethnic and racial
matter students are less gifted that I
mean who was who wants to make that
argument yeah it's not it is not the the
reality of the matter and what you find
there are some really neat programs for
instance this one program called project
bright where they taught gifted
behaviors to every student so they just
they assumed well everyone in this
school system was going to learn
something from gifted from behaviors
that you know the gifted students tend
to have they kind of tried to distill
how do gifted students think you know
and can we teach this and they taught to
every student in in the school and they
thought after teaching it a like 25
percent or so more ethnic and racial men
are students all of a sudden qualified
for gifted education and once you gave
them a chance to learn these behaviors
and traits so I think we need to be very
wary about about treating these labels
as though they're an essence of a person
you know sensualism you know a gifted
there's a key difference to me between
saying that child is gifted and that
child was labeled as gifted to me the
former is an essential ISM argument
you're saying that's the essence of that
person the other one is you're saying
well we recognize something in that
person that we are giving them a label
so we can give them greater resources
but it's very important that we don't
fall prey to the idea that because
someone was labeled as gifted then
therefore that is the essence of that
person and it doesn't change and
therefore those who don't have that
label the essence of their label is that
they're ungifted we have to be very wary
about falling into that trap if we want
to maximum
human potential